[Music]
it was a council the inquiry said where
children were put
in the path of sex offenders where young
people were pawns in a toxic
power game an authority that failed to
act
against abusers
even now comprehending the scale of what
happened in lambeth is hard
they were seen as problem children and
they were treated as problems
not as children and as human beings
that's fundamentally what was happening
so while lambeth is grotesque
and worse than others no one should kid
themselves
that there weren't aspects of this
happening all over the country
do you regret not doing more yourself at
the time we could all shout louder
i think the problem and what we need to
learn
is this was a systemic problem
whereby the whole system was rotten
and therefore when the system's rotten
individual children
get dumped in it and they're treated
like third class citizens never seen
again
at the time lambeth was a local labour
council fighting
tory cuts the report said that the focus
was more on politics than on protecting
children it said that in the 1980s
politicized behavior and terminal
came to dominate the culture at lambeth
council bullying racism and nepotism
were found to have thrived in the
council in a context of corruption and
financial mismanagement
at angel road the report said children
were systematically exposed to sexual
abuse
some were younger than five the council
was criticized too for employing staff
it knew
posed a risk to children and not acting
against known abusers
or tackling the brutal harsh culture in
its homes
in regards to lab of council the inquiry
spent a lot of time and effort to
conclude what everyone knew
that they were guilty of failing to
protect children they knew this because
lambert
paid out over 70 million due to our
investigation
in regards to the police just a
whitewash
these are of course historical failings
the report said the council's apology
was fulsome
but only recent and said the true scale
of abuse against lambeth's children
will never really be known ali fuldski
sky news